c'est là monsieur quelques assis en
poupe dans ce livre qu'elle sait aimer
nous allons donc faire une interview par
amour
le mouvement baptiste ne va pas bien na
est ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
arrêter d'écrire non arrêté de publier
oui arrêtez d'écrire du beau c'est beau
c'est beau est-ce que 20 mo ou seriez
prête à ne pas faire d'enfant
oui on va faire six enfants aussi est-ce
que par amour ou seriez prête à cacher
quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer
oui où est le tuer avec lui même le lait
il a tourné l'escb amour je la mets dans
mon spectacle fait un carton au zénith
de montpellier baisers volés
est-ce que par vous seriez prête à vous
mettre à la drogue n'ont pas si vous
n'aimez pas vraiment alors menacé qu'il
trompe pas elle drague pas est-ce que
par amour vous seriez prête à prendre 17
kg à aller faire les perles
qu'est ce qui va vous restez est clair
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
accepter quelques infidélités
non
là
non est-ce qu apparemment là vous êtes
compliqué quand même parce que bon
est-ce qu auparavant vous seriez prête à
accepter qu'il ait une maîtresse non
est-ce que par amour c'est la question
clotilde courau vous seriez prête à
embrasser 100 fois la mise et
chaussettes sales
oui chaque chose et chaque show 700 fois
à est-ce que par amour ce qui sauf qu'il
est à la question est-ce que par amour
sans l'avoir d'échangisme l'allemagne 6
mds que par amour vous seriez prête à
vivre à trois avec ce lien et les miens
n'ont pas rejoint la seule chose à faire
pour lui en fait sept tués et léché les
chaussettes presque pas vous seriez
prête à aller a vécu dans un club et
chauvin
je n'ai même pas
à
alors j'aime que les hommes qui
supportent qui ne supporte même pas
l'idée de me partager en fait un potage
iata patins à melilla tapotage savary
via la fois des impôts talent est-ce que
par amour ou seriez prête à devenir son
esprit des gens sont espacés d'accord la
presse que par amour vous seriez prête